في منزلها في العاصمه الرباط تضع السيده
سهيله الترتيبات الاخيره على اغراضها وما
ستكون في حاجه اليه قبل موعد الرحله من
مطار الملك محمد الخامس في مدينه الدار
البيضاء انا كنعتبر تقرب الى الله لان باش
كتقرب على الله كتكون الهديه ديالو هو شنو
اللي كيكون الوالدين في الدنيا
هي صدقه جاريه
او لا ابن باركي يدعو لك يقترب السيد احمد
البوعشراوي من عقده الثامن انتظر اربعه
عشر عاما للحصول على فرصه لاداء فريضه
الحج ولم يفقد الامل الناس
التيسير وجاب الله الحمد لله ونشكره انا
فرحان الى اقصى درجه
فرحان بزاف والشكر من المرتقب ان يتوجع
حوالي 34 من المغاربه من ضيوف الرحمن عبر
سبع مطارات مغربيه في اتجاه السعوديه
لاداء فريضه الحج عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات